la crisis económica Argentina sigue
escalando luego de que este martes el
Instituto Nacional de estadísticas y
censo oficializará que la tasa de
inflación anual superó los tres dígitos
por primera vez desde 1991 el índice de
precios al consumidor se elevó el
102,5%, un contexto de compleja
resolución que agota a los ciudadanos No
sí me enteré que es un 100% anual no no
se puede no se puede totalmente
sí que se vayan todos Así estoy cansada
cansada cansada cansada
cansada de todo esto de los políticos de
que se pelean de que y la gente se muere
de hambre según los datos del gobierno
el aumento inflacionario de febrero
alcanzó el 6,6%, un número más alto del
esperado y ya acumula el 13,1% en lo que
va del año en tanto que en las zonas del
Norte las más pobres del territorio el
incremento fue mayor al 7%, los
productos que más subieron su valor
fueron los alimentos y las bebidas otros
síntoma negativo para los sectores más
vulnerables porque no hay nada no hay
plata la gente no tiene Entonces cómo
compra
los otros días Vine le digo Dame dame
tres mandarinas dos naranjas dos banana
y medio kilo de tomate cuando me dijo
650 pesos y que no sacar todo déjamelo
tomate porque no tengo más plata la
inflación es un problema crónico que los
últimos gobiernos no han podido
solucionar pues a sus promesas mientras
para los argentinos el crecimiento
constante de precios sólo significa una
cosa ajustar el bolsillo y comprarlo
estrictamente necesario